Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
What should I talk about today?
Maybe I should talk about a language
spoken by tens of millions of people.
Maybe I should talk about one of the
world's major language families or a
country with stunning linguistic
diversity.
No,
I think today I'll talk about something
a little different.
Today's topic is Toky Pona Toki Pona.
What's that?
Toki poner is a constructed language,
meaning that it did not arise naturally,
but it was created by someone in order
to fulfill certain criteria or a certain
vision.
The most well known constructed language
might be Esperanto,
which I made a video about a couple of
years ago.
Toki Pono is another constructed
language that I thought was unique and
interesting enough to make a video
about.
It's not spoken by very many people,
but it's well known amongst fans of
constructed languages.
The name Toki Pono means the language of
good and as a minimalist language.
The idea behind it is extreme
simplicity,
especially in its core vocabulary.
The purpose of Toki Pona is not just to
simplify communication,
but to simplify your own thinking.
To force yourself to eliminate
unnecessary information and ideas and
focus on what's really important.
Toki Pona has a core vocabulary of only
123 words.
Yes,
you heard that,
right?
123 words.
You can learn those hundred and 23 words
in just a couple of hours using an app
like memorize or unlucky.
I should point out that.